in this video we're going to talk about
how people can interact with
influence
and participate in society
when you do so you're participating in
civic life
which is distinct from your private life
private life includes all the ways that
you pursue happiness through
relationships hobbies or your job that
is if you're not a member of government
civic life includes all the ways that
you might take part in solving the
problems of your community whether
that's by volunteering in civil society
making rules or laws
or serving in a government body whether
that's the school council or the u.s
senate
so if you like playing video games
playing for fun is part of your private
life
but if you joined a group petitioning
for more representation of diverse
characters in video games
you'd be entering into civic life
then you're not just doing things that
make you happy individually
you're striving to have an effect on the
lives of others
so when you step into civic life you
will become involved with politics and
government
although you often hear them lumped
together they're not actually the same
thing you could say that politics is
something that you do an action
politics encompasses all the ways that
people reach agreements in a group by
negotiating compromising or voting
and those people might not agree with
each other but through the political
process they agree to be bound by the
rules that they've negotiated together
so on the large scale politics describes
both how congress debates bills
and how you and your brother decide who
does the dishes
then there's government government is a
noun
and it describes both the institutions
like the supreme court or the city
council
which make and enforce laws
as well as the people who serve in those
institutions
so government could describe both fifa
the international governing body for
soccer as well as the referee whose job
it is to enforce the rules that soccer
teams and players agree to abide by
okay so now that you've learned about
civic life private life
politics and government here's a pop
quiz
i'm going to give you a few scenarios
and you see if you can match them to the
correct term
first up ayla's church provides food and
shelter for the homeless community
during the winter to keep them out of
the cold
is this an example of
civic life private life politics or
government
pause the video here and see what you
think
if you guessed civic life you're correct
ayla is participating in what we call
civil society here which you might
remember from another video
civil society includes all of the
voluntary institutions that people form
and join outside of government and the
market she's doing something for her
community
okay next the supreme court here's a
case about internet copyright law and
the first amendment
is this an example of civic life private
life
politics or
government this is government the
supreme court is part of a governing
body that enforces the rules
okay last one
jeffrey a representative for the aarp
reaches out to senator rodriguez to
provide more information on the impact a
bill making its way through the house
will have on senior citizens he wants to
secure senator rodriguez's support when
the bill reaches the senate is this an
example of civic life private life
politics or government
if you guessed politics you're right
jeffrey is providing information hoping
to influence a decision that will affect
others
okay thanks for playing keep practicing
your skills in the exercise for this
lesson